I'm not sure what direction they're
going to head but I think that I think
that what we're going to see is that
there's has been really a very large
influence of Thomas kranz on the museum
world in general I know that doesn't
answer your question because by the time
this comes out frankly they could have
hired someone and it won't really make
any sense but I'll say that there were
things that for example branding when he
came in from the Yale School of
organization and management and he was
talking about Brandon and everyone said
off this is completely inappropriate for
the world of fine arts museums now they
all talk about branding for example the
start de the legacy of this idea of the
starchitect is a little mixed and in
fact after the success of the Bilbao
Guggenheim there were plans for all
kinds of other Guggenheim's in Austria
and Rio and Mexico in Taiwan all of the
metastases architects and none of them
happen
because all of these projects again are
combinations of finance diplomacy
politics local governments they're very
hard to get off the ground and in the
end a place like Bilbao where there's a
provincial government which really had a
lot of money that was a very special
case in someplace like Rio where there's
not that kind of money because the
standard of living in Brazil is very
different than the standard of living in
northern Spain it's much harder to get
something like that off the ground
you